well earlier in this newscast we first
reported on the stunning resignation of
raiders president mark padani stepping
down
made a statement talked about his dream
coming to fruition
and that bringing the oakland franchise
to las vegas and playing
in the two billion dollar stadium was a
dream well mark but dane
he was around from the very beginning
sharing insight into the progress
on that big project he's a raider always
once a writer always a writer that's
what they say right
he got the draft here but there's one
thing that he'd love to see
here before stepping away i'm sure
and i'll just tell you that we got very
positive feedback about both the draft
to be
awarded for either 2019 or 2020 and we
have a meeting
in about three weeks in dallas to make a
presentation
for las vegas to be the host for one of
those drafts and the super bowl
would be for either 2024 or 2025. um
remember all that talk while replacing
mark bodaine on interim basis will be
dan ben trill you can see him in the
background he's the guy with the shirt
and tie with the black shirt right
there he's been with the organization
for a number of years